eu vou falar pra vocês sobre cogumelos é
para que vocês entendam o que que seriam
estes cogumelos como funciona eu falar
vou falar como que que aconteceu à minha
história com estes cogumelos
logo que eu entrei na que eu comecei
essa história de chefe de cozinha eu fui
estudar gastronomia e tudo
eu sempre ouvia sempre alguém que me
inspirou muito foi alex atala e eu
sempre ouvi ele me falar sobre ele
observou ele fala nas palestras e
entrevistas na tv sobre cogumelos
comestíveis do mundo inteiro e ele
sempre era muito incomodado ele falava é
impossível que a amazônia não tenha
cogumelos comestíveis porque é um lugar
extremamente propício para isso a gente
tem muita mata muito tempero há muita
umidade e o qual é o sentido de nossa
gente não trabalhar com cogumelos
comestíveis ainda né
e aquilo sempre foi quando na minha
cabeça eu sempre pensava que há no
mínimo a obrigação de reencontrar estes
cogumelos porque afinal de contas eu
estava aqui e não tinha por que um cara
de são paulo que é um chef muito
expressivos saber mais do assunto do que
eu
eu comecei a pesquisar sobre isso enfim
mas nunca eu pensava poxa se o alex
atala não conseguiu nem eu ainda
começando ainda fazendo estágio por que
que eu vou conseguir trabalhar com isso
e aí um belo dia eu fui para são gabriel
da cachoeira
minha primeira primeira ida para lá em
e eu gosto muito de fotografia e eu
estava andando pela mata eu fui o
convite em preencher o protocolo eu tive
que visitará os caboclos que tinha uma
plantação de cebolinha chicória imagina
é louco pra ver coisa de e vital formiga
e os caras não a gente tem que visitar
plantações de cebolinha então eu estava
andando lá e aí eu vi uns cogumelos
lindos no chão e fui lá e fotografei e
aí acabou por falou pra mim o rapaz que
você está fotografando os cogumelos
eu falei ao primeiro porque eu gosto
muito de fotografia e segundo porque eu
hein
quero encontrar um cogumelo comestível é
aqui é a na amazônia e para minha
surpresa ele falar porque não falou
antes que a gente tem um monte que a
gente consome
vamos ver então os cogumelos e aí foi
quando a gente é eu e ele me levou até o
lugar onde ele tinha estes cogumelos
aí eu peguei um punhado de cinco belas
que aqui tem alguns deles que eu peguei
na época eles comeram primeiro
obviamente porque alguns cogumelos você
só come uma vez né
e aí é eu fiquei imagina né tava
começando minha carreira estava com um
produto incrível na mão falei cara e
esse
essa é a novidade do do século dada
dentro da minha área e aí eu fui até o
inpa o instituto de pesquisa da amazônia
e fui procurá-la se tinha alguém que
trabalhava com cogumelos
para minha surpresa é encontrei a
pesquisa o grupo de pesquisa da doutora
no mx caua e ela trabalha com cogumelos
aqui na amazônia há mais de 20 anos
então assim o meu primeiro choque foi
que eu não soube onde procurar não
precisaria ter dotação gabriel da
cachoeira para entender que esse
universo de cogumelo já já existia muito
tempo eu poderia ter ido ao inpa batido
na porta e ela foi super super simpática
atendeu super bem e aí a gente começou
uma história com cogumelos bloco como
conhecia no mma ela a gente foi muito
muito alma nas matas atrás de cogumelo
caçá cogumelo e eu vou falar vocês é
muito sofrido só quem já andou assim
dentro da mata já fiz isso muitas vezes
é você tem muitos insetos é picada de
mosquito para tudo que é lado você é o
calor escaldante da floresta umidade né
isso exige muito da gente e aí quando há
uma das que essa essa fase dos cogumelos
foi novembro
isso já aconteceu em janeiro e fevereiro
atrás de cogumelos e tal e aí onde ela
me falou assim felipe tem um com melo
que a gente poderia continuar aqui no
amazonas
a gente poderia fazer isso então ela
começou a me mostrar isso que
eu vou apresentar para vocês é bem aqui
a gente tem uma linha do tempo é de
cultivo de cogumelos no mundo
então a gente tem aqui na china por
volta do ano 1000 os primeiros relatos
de cultivo de cogumelos pelo homem
aí é esse primeiro relato foi de shitake
foi o primeiro como melo a ser cultivado
e aí é a gente começou a pensar de uma
forma que a gente poderia cultivar o
nosso cogumelo ea gente tinha que elegeu
um porque eu descobri também no m
mostrou que há aqui os arredores de
manaus nós temos 34 tipos de cogumelos
comestíveis dentro de milhares que não
são comestíveis né
então a gente começou a trabalhar e tal
e agente elegeu a lentidão rafah única
como cogumelo que a gente iria continuar
porque era um cogumelo que tinha um
grande bônus valentino a rafah única não
é cultivada não existe em outros lugares
do mundo existe relatos dela ali mais ou
menos da região de miami até o rio
grande do sul
somente nessa faixa da américa e esses
relatos forem 40 horas com o último foi
em 60 a gente falou 'não vamos trabalhar
com isso porque a maioria dos outros
cogumelos e que os outros 30 e poucos
eles têm em vários lugares do mundo a
gente falou 'não vamos trabalhar com o
que é nosso
então há uma linha do tempo dos
cogumelos começam no ano mil e vai até o
ano de 2015 que foi quando a gente
começou a trabalhar foi quando nesse ano
a gente teve a nossa primeira produção
da lentidão a rafah única e eu vou
mostrar pra vocês um pouco de como isso
começou
aqui a gente tem os passos de como isso
funcionou é mais pra frente vou falar
pra vocês sobre a fazenda que é nossa
parceira
nós temos aqui já com o grupo de
pesquisa da onu e meia as sementes
inóculo que ela fez dentro do inpa então
ela pegou os esporos dos cogumelos que
tinham nessa fazenda e colocou é criou
mais sementes multiplicou isso para
depois a gente fazer o processo de de
plantar os cogumelos 'ana na madeira
aqui a gente tem é essa essas madeiras
que são castanheiras
essa fazenda efe
no quilômetro 240 é de quem vai tentar
achar a e essa fazenda ela tem um milhão
e meio de pés de castanheira de
reflorestamento
então eles têm vários talões de madeira
e eles precisam a cada pouco tempo é
fazer o desbaste dessas madeiras ou até
tirar as árvores que não estão boas para
que as outras que são melhor então essa
madeira que a gente usa ou seja a gente
não precisa derrubar uma moto de uma
árvore da da mata
muito pelo contrário que a gente quer é
uma tentar mesmo então a gente planta os
cogumelos aqui nessas madeiras
depois é depois de um tempo mais ou
menos de 16 a 18 meses
a gente dá um choque térmico engraçado
disse que a gente foi por japão ano
passado e nós somos no cultivo de
cogumelos de shitake e aí o shitake do
mesmo gênero da lente no iphone cané a o
shitake a lentidão é do dci ea ea nossa
lente no la afônica e aí é o eles
demoram dois anos pra conseguir produzir
o cogumelo a partir desse momento dessa
primeira foto já sou ansioso e estava há
dois anos aqui pra gente esperar esse
cogumelo né
mas há um ano e meio começou a perceber
que a etapa tendo algumas alterações na
madeira que não eram comuns ea gente
descobriu que por conta do clima porque
não tem inverno a gente tinha as
madeiras esse processo chegava em seis a
oito meses
então é um processo muito mais rápido
depois desse processo a gente dá um
choque térmico na nessa madeira e depois
de uns 20 dias a partir do choque
térmico a gente tem os cogumelos aqui
está ele a doutora noêmia essa foto foi
logo no começo acredita que em 2013
ainda esse processo ou já foi 2014 e 14
ea o nosso já o cultivo foi esse ano aí
há uns dois ou três meses atrás e aí
com tudo isso a gente precisa é mostrar
o que a amazônia tem de diferente e que
a gente pode agregar com isso então eu
separei algumas fotos de uns pratos que
eu já fiz pra vocês entenderem como
funciona
nesse universo já dessa biodiversidade
toda a mesa é aqui tem um prato que eu
fiz uma apresentação em 2013 que na
verdade é um dos cogumelos bem
pequenininho se você como esse prato
obviamente vai ficar com bastante fome
mas são três espécies de cogumelos que a
gq são selvagens que a gente só consegue
na mata mesmo não não existe cultivo
deles
a outra esse cogumelo foi um cogumelo
muito importante para mim porque foi o
primeiro que eu tive contato e ele é e é
bem chatinho chama também a orelha de
pau é parece uma cartilagem e você
provavelmente já viram e a gente
descobriu que quando coloca ele no fogo
ele infla e ele fica parecendo um suflê
assim é muito bonito
só que o problema é que quando você tira
do fogo na mesma hora ele muda então não
dá pra ir até a mesa do cliente com isso
né gente não conseguiu fazer senão a
gente vai conseguir
e aqui e aí qualquer problema mas tem 30
e poucos tipo de cogumelo que vai
cultivar um né
o primeiro passo porque esse cogumelo
não existe nos outros lugares do mundo e
segundo porque esses cogumelo é a gente
como eu falei antes era muito difícil e
até a floresta a gente passava horas na
floresta e muitas vezes a gente voltava
com 1 100 gramas de cogumelos sabe 60
gramas 120 gramas e aí a gente começou a
entender que aqui deve ser muito caro
com a gente pra gente vai dar um prato é
preciso que você tem que passar um dia
inteiro cantando cogumelos e vender à
noite porquanto se trata
o tempo hoje é dinheiro então a gente ou
não vamos ver tentar um cultivo nós aqui
já tem um pratinho também de 2013
com estes cogumelos têm alguma serve
vinhos alguns moinhos mas assim sempre
quando a gente lançou um novo produto a
gente precisa dar foco total ao novo
produto não posso colocar o outro para
que se sobressaia sobre ele
aí eu tenho aqui também outros prazos
que a gente fez um bom jogo - esses mais
amarelinhos aqui são a lente no afã nica
esse aqui é um piloto também é um outro
cogumelo super saboroso mas também um
pouco mais difícil de conseguir na
natureza
e obviamente estes cogumelos todos que
eu sempre provei sempre teve o aval da
doutora emília é eu me preocupo muito
com isso porque afinal de contas é muito
sério né o consumo de cogumelos tóxicos
pode realmente fazer mal
então é eu sempre eu acredito que aqui
deve ter poucos cozinheiros mas não dá
para se aventurar com isso viu gente o
negócio é sério tem que tem que ter
alguém que entenda aqui também um prato
para você entender as texturas
diferentes de cogumelos aqui eu fiz 11
um radinho é triturar ele na verdade
depois fiz um crocante como se fosse uma
farinha de rosca crocante assim fica bem
legal ea 5ª nosso cogumelo do cultivo
então além de noah rafah única
depois de todo esse processo depois de
do começo de 2013 até 2015
a gente conseguiu chegar nesse resultado
que nos deixa muito orgulhoso e mostrou
que é puxa a amil amigo e 15 anos se
produz cogumelos ninguém nunca risco não
existe relato do cultivo desse cogumelo
mundo e quando perde me convidou eles
falaram olha a gente quer mostrar o
potencial que nós aqui dentro temos pra
cá pra nós mesmos porque eu já dei essa
palestra sobre cogumelos várias vezes só
que eu tenho certeza que pouquíssimos
amazonense me assistiram isso me dói
muito porque afinal de contas a gente
faz pra gente não faz para vender pra
são paulo acho que deveria sempre ser o
contrário a gente deveria trabalhar pra
nós e depois vender para o mundo né
então aqui pra vocês entenderem a gente
montou uma engrenagem que eu tenho a
fazer era anã que cede a fazenda
inteiramente para a gente fazer as
pesquisas a fazenda dona no quilômetro
240 sentido itacoatiara e essa fazenda
tem tem as castanheiras que a gente pode
usar à vontade eles é a gente encontrou
vários desses cogumelos lá
foi de lá que ele veio lá que de lá com
os esporos vieram então ele ceder os
esporos para que a gente conseguisse
fazer a semente inóculo a gente
conseguir produzir o inpa ea outra parte
importante da engrenagem são 20 mais de
20 anos a o grupo da doutora no mr
pesquisando sobre cogumelos
é esse projeto incrível na gaveta e aqui
eu deixo esse e se esse apelo talvez com
todos vocês que às vezes a gente é ea
gente espera é o que eu fiz eu esperei
sentado lá possui os cogumelos e às
vezes dentro de todas as áreas têm
pesquisas incríveis que são feitas estão
em gavetas estão armazenadas porque
ninguém vai atrás ninguém sabe
esses pesquisadores estudam muito pra
que a gente use isso não para que isso
fique guardado numa gaveta né então inpa
que acreditou na fazenda não acreditou
na gente para que a gente conseguisse
fazer esse processo acontecer
o restaurante banzeiro foi é o terceiro
ponto porque a nós entramos com a idéia
de dar valor agregado ao produto para
que esse produto também não caia numa
feirinha a gente quer dar um valor
agregado colocar nos melhores
restaurantes do brasil no banheiro em
manaus e e outros restaurantes também
porque nós entendemos que quando cair na
mão de chefs do brasil inteiro a gente
consegue agregar valor ao produto e
consegue transformar esse produto num
meio muito maior né
e aí toda essa engrenagem todo esse
nosso trabalho move o que é o nosso
verdadeiro legado pra isso
o uso da biodiversidade da amazônia a
gente sabe que a amazônia tem coisas
incríveis né eu acho que o grande
quintal do mundo então assim a gente tem
tanta coisa para usar aqui e tanta coisa
legal a gente não precisa derrubar uma
árvore a gente não precisa fazer
queimadas sabe poxa esse cogumelo a
gente a partir do momento que ele está
plantado a gente pode colocar ele dentro
da floresta mesmo ea floresta mesmo hoje
é a estufa dele para o sul o cultivo de
shitake tem que ter temperatura
controlada então essa temperatura
demanda energia
se for ela às vezes tem que ser mais
quente mais fria a gente aqui o nosso
processo de energia a gente precisa na
furadeira na hora de fazer o buraco e eu
acho que só o resto todo ele é um
trabalho totalmente sustentável
totalmente degradável o que torna muito
bacana então a o alex tem uma fala que é
muito bacana ele disse que a
biodiversidade quando sai da boca não
tem
a loura mas quando entra na boca tem
muito valor e é isso que a gente faz com
esse produto porque as pessoas que
provam os cogumelos
elas entendem o valor que têm esse novo
produto um novo ingrediente nós
entendemos que é a amazônia é incrível
né
poxa às vezes os turistas vêm para cá e
eles já ficam malucos quando eles como
as farinhas os tupis nossos peixes
só que a gente quer mostrar que a
amazônia tem muito mais do que isso esse
é um ingrediente de milhares que a gente
ainda tem que expor aqui dentro da
amazônia então é esse novo ingrediente
com o sobrenome amazônia o que é muito
importante que pode ser com certeza vai
ser super valorizado por chefs do mundo
inteiro porque afinal de contas o japão
por exemplo os países que mais consomem
cogumelos no mundo imagine para um
japonês nec e acha isso aqui é algo
incrível a gente já viu grupos japoneses
por aqui poderem comer lá na cidade
deles um cogumelo cultivado e com o
sobrenome amazônia
e aí também ou não por último mas não
menos importante é nova forma de
oportunidade de renda de emprego e renda
que acontece gente quando eu comecei a
andar pela pela pelo amazonas aí eu já
andei bastante
já passei são gabriel da cachoeira e sub
15 horas de barco ele pra cima eu
comecei a entender duas coisas
importantes antes quando ele deu a
palestra do sampa e aqui eu achei algo
muito bacana que ele falou que ele
estava falando dessa energia do rio e
numa dessas viagens a são gabriel da
cachoeira um pesquisador me falou assim
é quando você pula dentro de um rio
você se conecta ao mundo inteiro porque
a água do rio vai indo até chegar no
mário mário é tudo conectado e fiquei
pensando aquilo realmente não é quando a
gente está ali a gente pode ter uma
descarga de energia incrível e eu
entendi nesse nessas minhas andanças por
aí é que quem realmente preserva a
natureza e que a gente tem que pensar
antes de qualquer coisa é quem vive na
floresta porque as pessoas que estão na
floresta que lá lá elas são quem
somente cuidam elas vão fazer uma caça
de uma forma sustentável em casa para
vender pra ficar rico e descansam para
comer
eles não têm interesse em derrubar
árvores se eles vão fazer uma roça uma
roça que é tem da comunidade deles então
o incentivo para que a gente tenha para
que essas pessoas consigam desenvolver
os seus papéis de uma forma que elas que
seja bom para elas também pra gente é
muito interessante então nós pensa nós
entendemos que quando a gente é criar
uma alternativa de renda para as pessoas
que moram na floresta sendo essa forma
sustentável é algo que deixa que a gente
entende que seja um grande legado e
assim gente eu acredito que cada um pode
fazer cada um nessa sala de formas
diferentes podem fazer algo pela pelo
pela amazônia pelo nosso pelo nosso meio
então nós na gastronomia tentamos da
melhor forma com deixar nossa
contribuição para a preservação pra para
a valorização da amazônia de uma forma
sustentável então eu queria deixar uma
mensagem que eu acho que com um projecto
que muitas vezes tem muita gente
envolvida a gente pode fazer muito mais
pela amazônia pelo nosso entorno com
produtos que beneficiam uma grande
cadeia
muito obrigado